and but the vision behind it is
okay, so to speak, how can we take this
complex topic of taxes that
steam down and help people get the money
back what is
due to them and in the long term by giving financial participation to those
with whom no other fintech
actually talks
then means to look okay what
do you do with it in the money you can of
course take that to
pay the bill in the current phase
or also and that the perspective
then say okay maybe that is
also the first step to take the
tax refund and  How
to create to close this pension
gap Now follows a video on
a new career path and not just starting
something to be successful
or making a career somewhere in the
group, but simply the Martin Ott model to
be the first or to be there very early
on if somewhere a rocket  deliver
somewhere success is then to be there
quickly that's the Ma  rtin simply a
master but used to be on Facebook he used to
be on Jamba it is on
taxfix his pattern is on I
'm on and I'll be promoted and
partiz will become the boss if something goes wrong somewhere
how exactly it works what he's
doing now what the money  what the model of
taxfix and your taxes has to do with it, how
you can even save money with it,
maybe all of that comes up now with
Martin Ott, let's go,
welcome to the OMR podcast, an old
acquaintance is back, but known in
other, er, yes, people or a different
role  back then
now as unicorn was CEO
before that even
more careers welcome
first of all Martin I'm very happy to be back
here we
actually have to fill in at the very front because what you've
known for a long time as European from
Facebook you kind of used to have
here in Europe with built up in
Germany above all things but
even before that you have a  I've also worked for
charismatic entrepreneurs
somehow a bit runs
through your vita back then I
've been with Jamba right from the start
so I worked for the collector brothers
then I think Max Zuckerberg is more or
less the boss then what
texfix so
they are  these founders are also so
special you always have to tell them but
that was tell
your own words you already had
something on the
Kärbholz right from the start, so to speak, so
I’ve always been in general, of course,
in the tech scene or something
I always found technology-driven companies extremely exciting that simply
question the existing structures
yes the option the first startup is
namely made was then I
quit my studies at the WU wrote a
business plan flew to Japan
to found a company there
that was around the turn of the millennium  the so
consumer reviews makes for Japanese
products and platforms and
that  was
then at a time when it
turned out that somehow the
business model is all really great,
including the business plan and so then
the first internet bubble that burst
, so to speak, the monetization
of
banner spaces on mobile phones was a
bit earlier for that
and then I went back to Germany,
did my degree, so Mom
was happy, and
then the original goal back then was
to bring mobile internet to Europe with Jammer, and
then it turned out that he himself said
Olli Sommer, I don’t know  Founder
I was then CEO and
then it turned out that people
here in Europe didn't
want to surf the web on this black and white cell phone
but rather
play Crazy Frog ringtone down
but because successful
internationalization we are very
strong abroad it's expanding
all over the world  Gentlemen countries and yes after that
I moved to London to work in the market
that was this Mon  eygram with the
Smart so money transfer from
London to Poland to Africa there
was the Western Union Moneygram who
somehow wanted to send a 105
that somehow took 15
pounds or so and we
said with such a digital wallet it was
still possible  in the early days since that also works
for 50 cents and Skrill is
later Moneybookers then let's say
the first
or one of the first fintech unicorns
would say that today back then you thought
and I'm a tech
just right for that that was over
transferwise for  wise and then
had 30 million digitals and and
and then made this P2P
transfer market, so to speak, also then in the
area of ​​​​the started so it was like that before
add stripe just started so
all this pay with erication
now made the world a little
better  I'm in because Jamba can
always be discussed because
it makes the world a better place, but with
moneybook you're in on it
transferwise, I find people who
often have little money anyway, who
then often transfer the money back to their home countries
to make it easier
and somehow removing the fees
is actually a really cool thing,
that also fascinated me
about taxis, no, I should have
I didn't think that
she could get me so excited about taxes
and then do it at tax,
but what I also didn't realize is
how many people simply because the
topic is so complex and with
fearful doubts do not
submit a tax return at all and  then on
average more than 1,000 euros in
Germany alone with the Treasury Money that
they are entitled to and that's that's
something to talk about what he's doing about it
or how you're trying
to help people somehow but you were then,
so to speak, coming apart from
Moneybookers you are  then actually to
Facebook exactly right that was a very
early phase with Facebook  k yes it
really was like that it was
maybe not a startup anymore but scale ab
it was around the time of the ip-hausraum
there was still here in Germany
StudiVZ was the biggest competition at
that time and then I was there for many
years seven years  because I then helped to set up
different functions and
different
country regions, then of
course Instagram came along and wanted
that was probably
a very lucrative time for you
too, I'll put it like that, it was ultimately when you look at it, so I
started talking to Facebook it  It was still
2011 I'm a short my first
working day a few weeks after the IPO
but and in the first phase there
was the question at that time
what does such a business model look like
can I work at all and
then we proved to myself that it can also
scale and that was it  then yes,
my role is to
push this internationalization forward again at
the Africa I have at times  Africa
made that gave me 100 million people
on the Facebook platform but
no office yet on the continent and so
that was so much development work that
also what is your best
the best marksackerberg anecdote
I don't have a specific anecdote right now
but I can only say  I always found it
enormously impressive
because it reflects very much
what you might
not think from the external image but
very, very really reflects super
smart, of course, enormously smart and
I was very, very often over there at
melopark  but he was also
here in
Germany a few times and yes he did
a town hammer and there were a
few very funny things but it was
quite a while ago but it was a very,
very exciting time but I
learned a lot
there is
no special Olli either  Samba
anecdote, but I'll tell you
something
like that, which I certainly
learned in the early phase was the
whole thing  The topic of focus execution, how do you
quickly build up and scale and
so always in comparison to what is
now my focus and completely different,
much more sustainable to really
look at the whole topic of employee
development, how do you look at rooms,
like the culture at taxfix  aligned in such a
way that the greatest assets are
your people, the people who work in the
company and of
course want to enable them want to invest
want to see that you create an environment
where they are not only productive but
also happy in the long term and don't
go somewhere else and so and that is  already
what is driving me around then we will leave
the completeness for a moment, of course,
but the
discussion of the rework station that seemed
totally understandable at first, of course, okay,
thought all those years on Facebook,
someone is now going to wework and that was the way it was back
then when you looked at it from the outside
looked at the big thing, the
odds are off the ground and everywhere
then it suddenly
imploded in a completely different way than you thought
it was also another
industry for me real estate real state
I didn't know that also worked in the
phase like it did
many decades ago and
bring Flex in there and look at it
how do you do that I found it enormously
exciting I came at a time I
don't know if you've seen the crash
yes the capable I can
you say more about the last episodes
where the party was over and then what
actually  more of a major structuring
topic
so you signed
probably the party wasn’t over yet and
then you came in the morning
exactly so it was the phase
before the IPO IPO preparation, so to speak,
but the goal was even then to
see how I translated you clean
structures  that is sustainable is
that the lawsuits are put on hold
then the IPO didn't work
out then I'll put it like that if  you look at
the last two episodes like
Crash so that's what I did in this phase
to
look at how
lastingly you had doubts in yourself, so to speak,
how could I do that
from the outside I mean you made a
conscious decision to go not
see that it  it would end like that, but it was
then, or you say no, you
couldn't have seen that because
the contract was offered, so to speak, at a
time when you had to believe it was going
great, many investors believed well,
I still
believe in the product in general  what I have seen before
and also loved myself and also
and also in the market I
really believe in it then the question is how
are you successful in the long term and
how do you manage it that is really
sustainable and also a sustainable
corporate culture is everything
and for me  the learning curve i had
no idea about is not just
real estate i then suddenly had
hundreds of people in
construction crews d  he built community, so to speak
, I can only do digitally before
that was suddenly in the physical
area where someone was standing by the beer
and and and so that was
definitely not experienced for me in the area
before and
I have to have a strong learning curve here  out so that
's no use no that wasn't
very clear for me to look at the task how
do you manage it to be sustainable on a
sustainable basis let me put it on such a healthy
footing and then I had this
restructuring, which I then
completed and then I did  I said
now I'll do something new again
okay how does it always happen that you change,
so to speak, so now one is
fixed to the day, yes, the next change
then came, there was
a break for a while, but how do such
changes come about, so it's always that you're
there  his your your so to speak headhunter
who addresses you in the
personnel consultant who would always have
your your whatsapp song ready and
says okay here's something new or or
are you looking around and say you're
actually up for it or taxfix I
've really spent a whole time here
talking to a lot of people
also vacationing together
lazily looking at something new like I'm thinking about founding something of
my own and so  looked at so many topics myself
and then
I can, so to speak, go to the taxfix
founders 2
Swiss Matjes and Lino
probably need two Swiss people who
are coming to Germany
and I really spent a lot of time with them
because my
first thought was
to really steer them
next years two decades really
with this topic taxes and
I used to I also thought about
when will that come from my my mother
was already totally stressed out after Christmas
and
somehow distributed papers to all the apartments
and looked and said she has
to pay her taxes  do so to the point
that they then kinda Silv  I
then pack the papers to the
tax office to pack it up and for
many years I thought that this
tax is the small one in Germany on
December 31st, but it is, so to speak, this
late filing that somehow had
not been handed in beforehand, okay and that’s
why it works like that  many people are more concerned with
the topic oh
stress and oh wow and fearful and
and he is now really
questioning that if I am
already doing how are many others also spent a
lot of time with the
two to see what is it  Potential that
's the right thing for a
corporate culture
and then I was super excited and
now somehow after more than a
year now I've been here for more than a
year these films aren't that
old it's five now we're six
years old  now and how did
the two of them come to do it
exactly they have moved to
Germany had
already taken care of another startup before  rt so
I think
one eye really both really brilliant
for really complex topics and
to steam down the simple
and that's what makes us really look today,
how do you manage such a topic
controlling that's
that's this old control unit is yes
you have to  somehow run
out forms over forms in
the language of you don't learn at
school so nobody teaches
how much to a tax return from
this official German what does that
actually mean and so and then there are a
lot of people who just say oh wow I do
n't know  how I do it and
somehow there are tax consultants who can
do this and but a lot of
over 10 million people in Germany
say they won't give it up at all and
leave over 10 billion with the
tax authorities
and the basic idea of ​​a taxi
is how  do you manage to control the
people who otherwise have no
access to these
financial systems?  such a
first step a finance it's the
next complex issue also what we
want to tackle how do you get there
to make these people easy and accessible and the solution back
then was an app with a simple
dialogue system so ask a few questions
from any catalog of over 3000
possible questions we steam it down
and it's like a dialogue system as if a
tax consultant would ask you what in
part yes no ask has to
enter what you take a photo of your
income tax return and then you can
see what your tax refund is
and can then decide okay there is
now off or not
and the managing director is then like that so
you enable the people who he
otherwise don't pay any tax that they
give one then they get their
tax refund and you get
a part of it as a commission, so to speak,
from the refund then it's with
us yourself  it so you give,
so to speak, there
answers the questions then calculate  we
issue your tax refund and if you then say you want to hand it in, it
costs a one-time
fee of €39.99, why not
listen and participate in the refund together
?  tell
me about the price point, no, if you
think about how many people today also
this this tax refund, it is even
after today, yes,
you know, in the OECD, I just
read that
over 45 percent of the people in the OECD and
they rich countries have less  as a
monthly salary somehow as a reserve,
so to speak, in the account, so that
means
that this thousand euro
tax refund is of course an
enormous
contribution to personal finances
, especially for the many who otherwise
do not submit their tax returns and who,
say well, have not been
able to afford this tax consultant and  always get
the maximum out of it and there was
simply the question of how do you really do it
I simple and transparent
so you still have to pay 39 euros
even if you don’t
get a refund no not that
so you can see what
kind of tax refund you get we
calculate it and then you can
decide do you want to hand it over or
not and there are
some who have to file tax
returns, so I can also say I'll
do it with ELSTER now and
go through all the forms
and so and Fuchs really put me in
there, there are also a lot
and there are also many who have
to  not give it up but we are both
we are we are both there for those
who have to give it up and these are just
people who have also received wage replacement
benefits  but the normal
employee, who is actually not supposed to give up
, but who is very, very many
M  Possibilities to sell things
that many do not even know so that's how
it starts now I have no idea such
a flat rate for advertising costs everyone can
sell such household-related services that is when you also
get an extra
bill from the landlord and see what the
craftsmen's services are there too  on top of that,
single parents can deduct
special lump sums, so to speak
, or we have fathers, mothers who are reclaiming childcare allowance
for the first time
up to
4000 euros and so a whole range of
things from the home office lump sum now was
just being
made from the company
here maybe because they are not
40 45,000 euros he is  still single without a family
what can he usually do like that there are
so typical assumptions what to
expect from the list with you yes it depends
entirely on whether he has additional income so to speak
and how so if now
for example from outside of here from
Hamburg lives and commutes,
for example  el set the commuter
flat rate and otherwise but right now with this home office flat rate are now 5
euros a day if it increases from 120 days
to 200 days next year you are also
somehow 1000 euros potentially
talked about earlier some are not all
are here  with us also some in the
home office so the question why
don't more people do it how
many users do you currently
have we have five million over 5
million app downloads
not only in Germany but also in
several markets just
right we are now beyond Germany
it is  but the number of people
you got money from
in Germany who say they don't
is a big milestone that was also,
so to speak, where we talk that's
also what we look at internally every
week with the Freies team
how much money we got
back for our customers
and last November we had
over a million  iarde that was the
milestone brought back okay for the
people, but one billion when I think
about it now, of course, with the different
countries our difficulty is
somehow to some extent to be appreciated,
but a few hundred thousand
people in Germany will already be using
the service, that can definitely tell you
yes exactly so anyway if
then also the other way around at that time there is a million
here yes how many employed persons
are there taxpayers pensioners there
are many more so it could be
yes there could be several 8-beat
numbers a million
who do that why do  there is still
very little communication problem,
many don't even know it yet, so
that's what we see, we see
a lot of customers who come to us who are
doing it for the first time and had no
idea, so now, for example, is on
October 31st and even if he  somehow at
10/33 at 11pm says okay now we know
do the tax return k  Then you
somehow hand it in with the app
within less than 30 minutes that's
not yet in people's
heads they're still thinking where
taxes
I don't understand the topic
no one taught me a
tax consultant I don't know how expensive
it is either  one must also say that many
tax consultants are also very important for complex cases
and so and we also
have many partners in this area
but these
cases are perhaps not the
most interesting cases of these simple
cases and yet it is this
complexity that is just somehow  we see
that here too,
we've also carried out studies
and
more than half of them are always simply
afraid of it, so not only in
Germany, somehow in Spain
it's also somehow, 48 percent of respondents
say they're really afraid
of the subject of taxes  Fear of
making a mistake or simply afraid
of this complexity,
so to speak  I would like to know what do I
have to keep ready probably
somehow my salary slips
something exactly no actually not
so first of all depending on what you
want to deduct everything
your salary is actually enough quickly
income tax return is enough if you take a
photo of it we will extract this data depending
on then  even if what sums that
are, ne for donations, for example,
up to 300 € is enough, your
bank statement does not need a
donation receipt, so there are a few
flat rates that you also apply, so that
you don't necessarily have to keep a
huge stack of papers wide
because of it
it's still like that in Italy too, it's really more like that
there too, we're quite a
lot of people who have to hand it in, so they
go to a
local wage tax office with their
stack of paper, then somehow make
an appointment a few weeks beforehand, then
it's almost  like a visit to the doctor and
pull his number sit there and then
sitting there older who then
typed the papers so to speak into the PC
and then made
sure that everything looked sound
and correct is
that tax consultants or don't have
consultants but so to speak we have uh
we have experts with us we we
don't advise  with control, so to speak,
but help with this
complexity that that down to then
we also have another product where the
people who still have questions our
customers who really want feedback from the
tax consultant there
on certain questions and that's
what we have  a tax check like that again
as an extra product where people can then
do that too and that
really runs through tax consultants but
otherwise that’s not the case with us and your
team so for people in total
we now have over 500
employees and continue to hire so  keep
searching people are essential
software developers for the fulfillment of
logic and the control exp  erten
we have over 90 90 tax experts and
but it is also really a focus
there too we have such a
special exciting just for the
expansion German tax laws very
very complex on how complex than in
other countries and from the very
beginning we saw that we  build our
placeform
control logic that is also not
hardcode, so you have
tax experts with us, so to speak, who can pull together control logic in such a
low code no code, so to speak
, because every year
new tax laws come changes
that of course also the basis then
to internationalize the whole thing well
because you can
easily cover control logic in other areas, so to speak,
and the two
founders came up with the idea simply
from observing the market
, they saw, okay, we should be able to do
it like this because actually
the question is almost why doesn't it already exist
for 20 years which in Italy
hear that is  Manually, so to speak, in
smaller offices where people are
helped, in Germany there is
always only Elster or
you have tax
consultants  we see that
now in Italy too,
if people don't know that these
alternatives exist, so now we see,
for example, we also have ours,
at the beginning we really have the very
simplest of cases and it's
really our focus because it's always a
mix  from how complex do you want to be and
and which cases will it really
cover they are all in all
meanwhile we also make pensioners, so to speak,
so we are also expanding the portfolio
and the range of other tax cases
and meanwhile we also see that
our customers are getting older and
now pensioners can also do this via app
and it's easy and of
course nothing that i  you originally
learned no and tell me the question I
guess you are not quite
happy yet how much turnover has he had so
far so I would so what do
you do in the year what can you expect
currently so below sales share so I
ask  but now it costs
€39 once a year, if you
somehow have a million customers now, which
just shot up into thin air
you don't quite have
then that would be €39 million, you
can calculate that,
you're welcome to do it that way  counting is like that
but
39 times the number of customers more
39 times the number of customers is correct
you have but also hate what we always
see is that many of our users also submit
their tax returns for several years
because you can
even do it for the first time  you can
retrospectively for up to four years, so
for those who have not yet
submitted their tax return, you
can also do so retrospectively for up to four years
then concentrate
okay, but I mean at least
I already said that you’ve been
Unicorn since the beginning of the year, I think
there was a group
that means I have to be really
moving on the topic, tell
me, so there are also investors  the
ones you know larger funds from
North America
big names
you describe your investment history a little bit
we did this very early on
and that was certainly also in the phase
when many people still wanted to question
the people now really doing their tax returns
with the app and that’s how it
was  yes also new territory came in very early on ready
alpine and kianum then in
the next phase valade too so
here in front
he is there also LP that is not the
experience that was found but
also with n26 and so exactly
they have a lot in this one too
fintech area then made Index
very great
and really really great and now
in the last round TBG is
part of this on  tari teacher plan
earn a lot of money with David
ne been there that can be seen
which funds were in there so
with this 20 billion were excellent okay
but and then you say
the Canadian form
that's also such an
accolade they look at each other  also very precisely where they
invest in Germany in Europe I
have to say they are very
long-term oriented and of
course management is also an issue, which of course has potential, which is
also very, very clearly and very, very
long-term
, and we can see
that it is  not only on the German topic
, you just talked about Germany
and Italy, but in many other
countries that the topic is a
model for
this in the USA, I won't say that
before, there have been for many
years intuet they have turbotext, for
example there  he came from the other
corner that came from this web area and
and offer that and yes how much money
is in the company in the meantime  ile
flown in with us yes over 300
million would that's a lot of
money yes that's right why why
don't the reasons control it themselves I
mean they are two young guys who
invented it or founded it
why do people say we'll get
Martin  Lino one of the reasons is still
with us the chief product
officer is also super really product
and visionary in the area and matt
the other simply decided for himself
that is a phase in
the company that is really fun is
also a start-up phase  I used to be and
have a certain size that's
not so anymore that it's what he's what he
enjoys every day because the task is simply different and then looked at what the right partner is,
so to speak
to take it to the next
level and how did it come to
you so you
didn't have that a bit right now so there was an int  ro
logically but or was it
some kind of classic personnel search as
usual that was that the intro
even came through a staff member on the case
okay so we also have many people we know in
common and so but this intro
even came through
now it's like
that  You, so to speak, yes, that's
how it was for me, at least that's how I know so many
from the industry who said okay, look,
Martin
[music]
you've managed or experienced it so much, even larger
companies
, it was a bit like that
a kind of accolade that you
are now giving the CEO that would
not do it for everyone with every salad with the
more so that's my feeling and
but it doesn't come for nothing
so you have to have a stake in the
company  you're
not just doing it for a salary
, but that's how I was,
as I said before, always very
active in business and of course that's what that's of
course  I'm also a
partner and so the package is
n't you get someone for
a salary somehow, but that
's a bigger package I've gotten
somewhere in the
meantime,
also on the subject of taxfix and it
was never like that with the topics before
I was never about the money honestly that's
not what drives me that does
n't motivate me the question I've always asked
myself is what really has to be where
I come up with a purpose where I
really see it has to be a big
topic where you really have a  has a great
impact on people and that's what's
also happening with the topic of taxfix, where
I've also seen a lot of other people
look at the adiotec, for example,
how many areas and
actually wanted to start thinking about what to
do and talked to many others
exciting stuff
and the topic was supposed to be again
I said it
's like that it's not just
millions and millions of people in now
Germany, as I said, almost 12
million who no longer
submit their tax returns, that means they are
not qualified and but the vision
behind it is to say yes, okay, how can
we take this complex tax issue
down and help people get the
money
back  what he is
entitled to and, in the long term, giving financial participation to those
with whom no other fintech
actually talks
, that means looking, okay, what
do you do with the money you can of
course use that to
pay the bill in the current phase
or else  also and that the perspective
then to say okay maybe that's
also the first step to take the
tax refund and how
to invest to close this pension
gap and then get the part again about
the tax refund next
year if you invest something and so
on that  is ultimately also the
vision where we say control is the
first topic that is  the first step where
we make it complex is make it very very
simple for people to
understand and there is another issue
finances are afraid too don't you learn
how to deal with it in school
what do you do with the money and get
them in and  to help him to
build up that in the long term, which I found
very exciting also in the
figures we did our study are
now the 18 to 45 year olds there, 37
percent of the women stated that they
had never filed a tax return
, that means and I think
24 percent of the men were or something like that,
so there is a gender there
too and of course it
also extends to poverty in old age and so on and that
is a huge, huge topic
that hardly anyone talks about,
the tax offices think there is something like that
So in the end they say they are missing money now,
so what was previously virtually not
requested by the citizens is
then in the state or in the municipalities
somehow stayed now you partly
take that out of it and then he does
a different kind of paperwork to you, so to speak,
that you give the tax office and
probably also more burden than mine.
every processing is from the tax office in
addition to alder somehow so they
are happier such offers for  You
are first of all, are also
close partners of ELSTER and
actually see us as a bridge
between the tax offices, because what we
do here is, on the one hand, we
create digitization, which
means that these processes are
simplified, so to speak, is our task  they
somehow used to have the idea of ​​making
the tax return on the beer coaster
so now we somehow have to do it digitally
and at the same time many
politicians there are conscious
tax breaks for very, very
many single parents and parents and
no, they don’t even get it  that's
what the wealthy have thought, yes I
I think it was always like that
, then they have tax consultants and of course they help to get
the best out of them,
but many for whom these
laws are actually intended do not achieve this
benefit at all and
therefore it is already a partnership with
politics because we can do it  that these
people who otherwise would not have this
access to get what they are
entitled to and what is also intended for them there
is still a lot
going on in the market now, I mean the other mutual
friend of both of us, I think
Florian was a very early comrade-in-arms of yours
I know Heinemann, with whom you have probably been in constant contact for Rocket days, and we
can both for a
long time, I have seen that he
recently joined a company, so not himself, but via
produce, he is active, it seems,
now I have in  also seen a
bit of the episode that you are waiting the
first one obviously but there is now
there's
already quite a lot of action there, by the way, that
shows how big the
need actually is in that area
and tell me where we've been for a long time
we're just at the beginning ne that
's where we're starting now in this
Zimmer so in this original
segment really enabling people to do this via
app now of
course you can
now also do it via the website and now
there are also tax experts who
help there and so on no and that
shows that it is different for the most
diverse user groups
There are needs and the fact that you
suddenly had this nice idea,
somehow you concentrate
on it and then there are somehow ten other
companies that are then also
financed and that now all
want to get in on the cake
is always like that, I've always been
focused on that  to do it right, so to speak, on
our own company there
, and I think we'll do it  very
very much correct if you
look at it also with our with
our customers i think this one that
fascinated me too yes when
i thought about it there it is
the right thing for me
so to speak and so i'm crazy about it  great
team, too, so Björn, our CTO,
was in Silicon Valley for 30 years and
then somehow helped build the global
marketing engine for uber and was
somehow intuitive at Salesforce and at
and already founded companies himself,
then somehow his page is there, I
think machine learning is made in  the
early yes, then somehow we now have
Eva new who was somehow with our
people office server get your guide and
then n26 from Christian so
on the one hand you have a team which really,
so to speak, not only has great experience
, you have already worked very successfully in one area
so to speak, this this DNA still from
our founders and the green
and this absolute focus really
and I always find that so impressive
that's what we're doing now that the customer is
always the focus, so it always has to be
looked at or is also reflected in the
usability of the app and our advice
and how many people
recommend us who have used us and say so  where
I didn't know so easy
look let's do that that's what makes us so
successful last week e.g.
one also a doer once a week
I do the all-hands where we do
open questions and answers and also
see and invite our customers
like that and then, so to speak, 17 customers are standing
on the chair and
then all the employees can ask the teams there
questions and answers and and and
just look to learn and always
look okay how can we they
can always be better and always
better products on  In the end I imagine
it to be a bit like the dream of
a CMOS
your
target customer group is almost everyone so
a bit so very broad you have
ka  about wastage because somehow a
tax return except for children or something like that,
if I understand it, everyone can
take part with you, so there are now,
from pensioners to students, everyone can
win something, uh,
so how does he do it, where do you
get the customers anyway, it's going there
really ready I have
n't seen anything in sports
sponsoring or something like that where you really have a broad
approach, I haven't noticed that yet
, but where does the news
actually get about
sports sponsoring, we haven't
done it yet, but otherwise actually
all the classic channels, so to speak
from the Apple Stores,
however, like Googles and girls of this
world, TV and podcasts and
other topics work there there,
so what is where is your target group represented, above
all, really very, very broad
and different and also depending on the
target group and what you focus on
you so what do you want
now more pensioners dra  If you have or have more
students or at the moment the focus is really
and that is still
the focus today really these simple
tax cases because we say there are so
many people today who don’t even file
their tax returns and these
are also other cases that tax consultants
do  so I said that for
many these simple cases are
not interesting at all because in case of doubt there is a
lot of paperwork and it doesn't
really come up saying the house has many
tax consultants they concentrate on the complex
cases or on
corporate customers and so on and we just sit
there  really the very, very simple
cases and age plays less of
a role, but rather earth plays
a role like
yes, do I have a tax consultant or
not or or or or what are
my own needs and otherwise there
are
different fears  that drive people
, then there are others who are
driven, so to speak, okay, I want to
optimize  en to get the best possible out of
the tax return in and the
largest possible tax return
others say I want it to be really
easy and stress-free and so these
are actually more of a wide variety of
target groups where we then look at how people
speak here a little bit I was
quite surprised we had  a few
months ago in my article about this
just mentioned startup from project
a so where they reinvested that
means express tax or something like that so the
competitor should I understand and
that was the story growing with tik tok
extremely strong so that’s kind of with
tiktok you explain to the people there that
they will get the money back and say
about the tax return and then I thought
okay, the tiktok target group,
that they already have tax claims somehow,
schoolchildren or or I was
surprised by the stands, but that seems to
be the case  now do not speak for the others
but it is already it is e  It's a
very, very big and broad topic that
really runs through all
age groups and sections of the population
and that's how we see it too and in
the end it's a company from
Germany that can really now
manage
to grow and
are in Europe or maybe even beyond  so [ __ ] see that our plan
because we see that is not a purely
German issue it is of course so
we are German companies and of
course we also have our headquarters here
and I also think it is a very good basis
as the German tax system is really so
complex and so
that the hypothesis  no but we see
we see that
said here earlier also in Italy in
Spain and also in
other countries that is actually an
international topic is also
I have read myself now 77% of
people spend
more than one day a year with their
tax matters if  you alone think
about what that means for a lifetime
, so to speak  only these fears and the
stress and so on before but also
just the time people
spend with it if you manage
to make it easier to give
back time not only give back
money so it is a huge
added value but the goal is what is
said again  beyond that,
this tax issue will really be seen as an
entry point and then, beyond the
tax issue, the
economic chain will really help people
with other issues as well, so
that you can then maybe make a decision together with the
then I don't know wasps
for the money that you
then get back that you say okay
man it's up to us we have the
following system idea for you something like that
exactly or
to bring the topic closer to him again first of all to
explain that's what we're doing
today  say so
what does that mean now, in part, it
somehow looks like a sad public and
the n26 that used to be one ha  t
somehow made shares the other made an
account now it's getting
a bit closer in
the end you're going to approach the whole world
from the other
side it's like that I think we're
talking to completely different people today namely
but it's quite  quite a lot of people who don't
even submit their tax returns, there are
certainly also many who also use the
other apps or
do other things, but there are lots of people who
might not
be trading stocks or
doing something else today, no, but to
pick them up first  and then
to look and for us also a topic
for doing it yourself partners these
are things today a topic that we
are already doing today which is also super
accepted the whole topic immediate
reimbursement so you can also with us
within now
somehow with instant SEPA in  10 minutes,
so to speak, get the money on your account
and therefore
have to ask
So that was also the reason why 300
million took out so much money, so
I thought to myself, what are they going to do
with so much money,
but is that also part of the money for
being able to make this refund immediately,
so he has to do it himself with a
partner bank  okay
that means that it is but still that
means you calculate it and
then give the people the money at that moment
what you projected what
is coming he then gives out exactly
or a part of it today we say we
get 50%
immediately it actually sounds so
nice to be so you help
other people
to organize money give it
immediately what does it cost as a new customer I
mean you imagine it must be
really cheap because once it's
on the market  it's okay here go to toxfix they
more or less get the
hundreds or thousands
out of nowhere so it
doesn't work before it was there it should but
you still have to get the customers s  agen to
run
that has already been said that it
really and that has me
so excited from the beginning is that even now
when I talk to people like this
they say that our customers are with us they
say I did it once and
also somehow  my friend told me about it
and so on just try I
never thought so of course this is a
very, very big channel for us so
new customers that means it's somehow
for a few euros get it to you new
customers
but so I assume that you just
don't now  but if they are for free in
this respect or or pay for the reference
no we don't do that so yes
we also have we also have
recommendation there
to recommend coupons coupons and that's
not the big topic now the big
topic is really that the
people know the  really used it for the first time
then also really
tell the family or
do it with others and so on and there for the
product  not even in the end, I imagine some kind of
gut feeling marketing channels that are completely
apart from the classic ones where you say
okay about partners with everyone I
don’t know about doctor visits or things that people
inevitably have to do or the
finance enter will send it to you
automatically if that  such a useful
product that you don't get it
leveraged any faster, except now via
classic marketing in meters and
and Google and and podcasts, but there
should actually be more going on
because I think it's really so
broad here that needs yes and  What
we see and that has
really grown organically with us is that
many companies have approached us and
said that this is a huge topic
for our employees and it's
like a benefits topic, I would almost say like
that  you say okay you
help the rubbish bin they have to submit the
tax return for the first time
or something is coming abroad  come
and that means we do it
now, so we also do
webinars and explain that the
tax topic is easy
and then we have a partnership, so to speak, with
companies that come to us and say
oh, why don't our employees at
Siemens or at VW help, where then  100,000 people
work write in the HR manager
once
here note dear people all go to the
change of day that will be a dream of yours
so if Siemens and VW
would do it it would be great
but we always talk about
income tax too, above all no
exactly that's mainly
income tax  So other tax
issues don't solve it,
I'll say it's not a really complex
tax issue today,
so or now the current issue
is the whole issue of property tax
latently always heard everywhere or how
difficult it is for people who
participate to be appreciated in the end
because people don't fill it out, so that
's a huge topic at the moment and w
we have um we also do the bus
together with our partner Lama is with
us are you somehow in the in
the app I could somehow I think
€19.95 and then you can use
the tool to make your property tax
easier, so to speak, it's like that  that
meanwhile I was just
describing this environment of the companies that are emulating
you, you have now
secured this round of financing and you
are now sitting there and you know you are the
best prisoner of all, uh, now
you can see how the others are
beating up the next one  Weeks then
you buy a little more,
so as I said before, we are
really focused on
our strategy and our big
focus is simply to continue
to build the best product, of course there is still
huge potential for growth here in Germany too
and then
ultimately beyond that  to
internationalize and also the whole
topic now
yes this to the people the topic of
finances auc  h closer and there
was still further growth that is that
is conceivable
is something new for you now to be
completely CO2 from the company
so to speak because you were there before only because we were on
Facebook at Jamba you were
always the so to speak
quick top manager but not
the CEO or something like that it's new I
've been to a gas station a few times before
and it's in Japan, so to speak,
but like every company there's always
a new role where you
can find your way and take a look  that what was
extremely important to me is also that at
taxix the really the topic of how
sustainable this culture and and how
do you set it up like that and that's no
longer look at whether we're
always a company that's
growing fast yes we are  now
since i came i don't even know how
much we had no idea 250 300
employees we hired over 500 so
massive how do you keep this
DNA that you really get the smartest people
st and at the same time make sure that
it also works in the long term, that they
don't somehow
burn out after a few years
and somehow say I somehow
missed my life and at the same
time learn and say wow, for
me this is the station that really
pushed me and me  I have some
great people around me who are not only super
smart but also nice so and then
to create this culture how do we do that
we have, for example, our
cultural interview processes
that, in addition to all the interview processes,
functional managers
do a coacher interview and can
possibly put it that means  if they say
no, then it's kind of weird, so to speak
, and it's also
exciting to see how a
company that is growing very quickly
is of course about
making the processes sustainable and taking on the
structures and
then of course you need good ones  People and
growing very very fast this culture
then also to keep what qualifies
you for I was just thinking about it with us
,
so
you have to have been with you for a certain while or have your
trust or or how do you call someone
out who then really
just keeps good people out with a veto
like that  can or simply yes in case of
doubt sets very important groundwork for
you so who will be better with you
because these are exactly as you say
people who have simply been there for a very long
time and and also that we see these
values ​​simply embody every day
and also  from the team, so to speak, then
as a very, very important one,
you have in many companies you have the people who
say wow, that is also a very, very
important culture and knowledge carrier
in the company and and they
will actually do that with us,
you are like that
I find an example for a species that is still
far too rarely discussed in Germany, let's say you assume
now you just
have s  I've had a lot of economic
success in recent years because all
stations are somehow because
I should ask people whether I'm
green or not
if you're there early if you
see something early and then join in as first,
second or tenth and
that's a few  repeatedly and every time
how an investor backs the right
company or sometimes at Rewe
doesn't flutter but often hits then in
the end it's probably almost a
better or more secure career than I
'm going on a topic now I'm a
founder myself try the crazy thing  waiting out of
love and seeing what is
developing well and where is
one already recognizable that it is running and
then I go back in that is
basically what you have always found for
yourself what other people also want to
recommend can only ever
think about it  so about your career do
n't think so much about building something new
and then see where goes what and then go
with re  in
here we are the question where is what ne
so that's like when wasn't always so
obvious that the topics to go
and even now control is now no
don't know so it's now not a
simple product yes where you say okay
you take that now  and just
do another language again and somehow do it
live in 100 countries, so it
's a very, very complex topic
, that's also what appeals to me, that
wasn't actually that, but for
me it was always more the task,
like  I said okay, I was
always looking for new industries.
I always looked, okay, which ones,
where can I learn something,
where is there a great need for
these industries and disruption, so
I didn't stay in one industry in Berlin
, I didn't say okay  I
'm
doing the attaxio in XYZ somehow now,
or after I'd done Skrill
and then called everyone and said look,
now here's the nä  The next fintech wave
is going to be fintech they told you
no, so I was actually always
looking for something new for me on the one hand as a
learning curve and at the same time as a
challenge, but also simply
to learn a whole new industry and
see what can be done there so
it worked  many topics it wasn't
the simple topics, so to speak, but
rather what I'm saying right now,
what really drives me around and
that at taxfix I really saw this vision of
helping millions of people with this
complex topic themselves at
home how much, so to speak
Fears and stress can trigger and
then and then to have a great solution
and then to say okay what does that mean
for you when there are 12 million
people who no longer do their tax returns in others
what does that mean they
are completely outside  from this
whole financial system from the whole topic,
so to speak, investment advice and
nobody talks to them like that  that's also a
huge topic and I think that's more of
what it's not trivial, but
I want to solve that, that's what
drives me around and then of course the
people and the culture because of
course you want to spend the time with nice and
smart people  but above
all with nice ones,
because life is too short for that, what is
the bigger one, so to speak, to get this company forward
or say yes to where
it can be, maybe because we
investors would like to have it, it's more like
this engine now  Building the app that
then automatically solves these tax issues
well
or it is more of a
marketing task in the end, how do I get
more people to use our service at reasonable, manageable costs
is one of the
challenges that we are currently
tackling and where it is very important  are focused on
it is a whole topic, how
do you internationalize a topic like
taxes, because every step is not just every
step  The system is different but also the
needs are different in different
countries why people do it and
how each individual market works
and stuff and what I said that
's not where you just sort of
adapt the language and it's
ultimately the same  and
at the same time to look at
the development of a platform further
then the whole thing not scaled and
so I think the biggest
challenge for us is still
great people I think like everyone else that's the be-all and end-all I think the
following  Luckily the company is
really super good people and that is also
the top people attract new
great people and so and
to keep that is actually the big focus for us
then
to look at nationalization and how do we continue to build in a
very very customer-centric
way  when these issues are over, but the app
can now do all the
cases you can imagine in Germany
that could now we ca
n't we are really focusing today
on the very simple cases we
deliberately didn't go into very, very complex
cases but from the rule of the
summer 80 20 maybe
the 80%, which then is the normal one
If so, you can and then that's clear for the time being, that means you now have the product more or less in place, so to
speak, and now
it's about the Marketing
Challenge getting people in and finding
the logic abroad again
, how do I solve it  now 80% of the
tax cases and how do I get
new customers in there
you can write about it
yes very well
you feel the somehow
changed
environment now in the boom time in the digital world
or also in the start-up world in the last few
years
you are too  still going
through the boom times, the
first rounds of financing, insanely
booming times,
something is different now, so
probably with you now  Yes, you
can even be a crises winner
because people need money even more urgently now
, obviously because of inflation
,
so it sounds like you don't
see at first glance where you are
suffering from it, on the contrary, or
is there something  you say oh that has
already changed a lot we are
now two things that address
one is the company side which we
also see in the ecosystem, so to speak,
and of course we see a
lot of ne now I'm looking at how
many employees
have to be laid off  to see
that's first that's
good for us at least because we
always have the issue of finding really good
people and such and
fortunately we're also very well financed, so that
's not the issue for us but
also a clear view of it  Ecosystem is
also about sustainably how
do you scale sustainably how do you manage
that and then what you are talking about yes they
on the customer side with the
people that's also because the subject of
clear taxes is of course
more of a safe haven on the business side, but
also because in such a phase we
help people
to have money their count so that the
average  you can
get is somehow there average
what is
on average the 1071 euros are okay
so substantial even just when you
look at it a
lot of money that's really a
lot of net money and if you react back
so sit down and
I know that  If you haven't done it before, you
're doing it two, three, four years
retrospectively then it's really a
lot of money, so thank me later
for this podcast, if you
still need 1071 euros
now, right after our conversation,
maybe the text 31.10 then that's
the deadline  is over exactly that
is the tax now for this year he
will but maybe is a question is
it a s  It's seasonal business,
so now you have to
put pressure on it,
so to speak, because if the message in December
or January, so to speak, doesn't help people that much anymore,
it really depends on the tax
process because many
who don't have to give up
don't have these control lines either  That means there
are many people who don't
necessarily have to give up, they can also give up all year round,
I mean that's okay,
most of them maybe even don't have to give up now
,
so enjoy the additional money, the
OMR podcast is happy for you, thanks
for being able to  just
let Martin come around I'm curious where you are and
what you're doing when we meet
here next time